mm go in breath my name is Brad back and
welcome to a new RPG maker horror game
it's been a long time it's been a long
time I missed these this one is called
hell oh hell oh get it hello well I
don't know anything about this game I
just know it has jump scares and it's
kind of short and I'm going away to
VidCon so I need to prepare video so I
thought this would be great I'm actually
looking forward to play it along the
lice is doing
I know see you what do I know
fine I guess I know oh [ __ ] I feel like
I should play this game with the oculus
whoa nope I'm not playing a video shut
up
ah Jesus ing hell hello pills here hmm I
just answered one not stupid iphone
stupid
it's the Steve Jobs you calling from
hell akari I like Steve Jobs and that
was it that was a bad joke and go bye
now
here's your extruder end one hello hello
what what what is going on here
hold hold your phone's okay fine I'll go
to the TV not willing to turn why not
yeah no come back why did I blow them
out I did not need to blow them out and
18 oh no no I come on so but things
change this ladder was not here I'm
lonely okay this is [ __ ] this game is
[ __ ] creepy decorative flowers ok
what if I
take some wine you die anyway welcome to
hell hello a game about da wash my te
alone win well the [ __ ] is that
skip it reflects the room jab yah Nuala
madam me na I can't deal with a [ __ ]
jump game shut up phone goddamnit hello
is this a curry answer
oh there was a woman behind me I don't
know if your brother saw in7 no reply
how many [ __ ] hey hello hello oh the
dialogue will come out this is a very
weird game but I like a hey where are
you hey Teddy it feels almost alive
well I'm not sure how I feel about that
I'm not gonna blow out the candles again
that's a [ __ ] shirt I'm uh should I
eat the food bras you tell me I heard
you say yes with your brain yes I can
read your mind
also your boyfriend is cheating on you
I'm sorry just kidding just longer tips
and I do not go well how about this
decorate many jab lab in cheetah okay
these [ __ ] jump scares needs to take
a chill pill what happened here did I I
swear to God that yo check stop okay
well the game was finna read I'm not in
the mood that thing is moving I swear to
God
gave us a total mindfuck why is it lit I
had a jab lad why I know tomorrow's our
anniversary but I can't just go where I
want
why don't you understand that I don't
get it I just don't I never missed it
before that's why I'm saying I'm sorry
ah just go die
what the kind of sounds like disco die
just go down
disco die disco die why would hey where
are you okay died escapes making me
paranoid as [ __ ] how about I just go to
sleep how about that
and for just let it be morning god damn
it nah I did it again I did it again
I did it again okay let's keep going oh
yeah
welcome to the mind of the great
PewDiePie half [ __ ] half McDuck
people always say like oh man I wish I
was stupid I'd be [ __ ] right now it's
not the [ __ ] was that sound - no [ __ ]
you I'm like I'm not bad down
it reflects the room there's a crack
here what is that uh I felt like I
expected everything okay let's check
these that these souvenirs from my
girlfriend why do they fall down I don't
know why did why does water make me
wanna pee how about I just [ __ ] go
back oh damn - I'm sorry so sorry about
that Teddy you know what you don't want
to be alone let you stop [ __ ] moving
Teddy don't touch my ass okay
don't touch don't touch it don't you
dare touch it love it
okay I guess
I can hear rather die than catch my hmm
okay you gotta you have some serious
explaining to do enough of this okay
please that table just keeps walking
dancing keeps dancing unseen force this
okay hello hello oh hey where are you
wait I know oh geez
some ring on my door I'm pretty sure
yeah baby baby it's a please more jump
scares hmm and it gives me a jump scare
I didn't even finish mine [ __ ] you
better [ __ ] stop calling
I'm Akari what do you want from me you
want me to read your [ __ ] book I told
you I was not in the mood are you gonna
fall down now - or Jess August ninth in
two days
it'll be six years of dating Kazuki I
decided I'll make this favorite meal I'm
sure I'll his favorite meal
I'm sure he'll kacica said he was sorry
he has an important business trip
tomorrow and I was already all done
shopping I can't even give him a lesson
well today makes six years Kazuki I know
work is rough that was too harsh on
phone yesterday I'm sorry Kazuki called
to say he'll be back tomorrow
it feels like it's been so long I better
meet him at the airport the entries end
here so they'd be in that part I'm sorry
okay I'm sorry and ten sweetheart diary
hello hello hey where are you wait for
me you boys want to do less than one
more ah geez change color
their eyes are blood everywhere [ __ ]
paddy Teddy's gonna bleed
you are you gonna dancing my goal what
do you want from me Akari
she slit a letter up in my eyes and I
like de comedia tomorrow
all right breast
so without for me I'm not risking
getting a heart attack I hope you
enjoyed this first episode I think we'll
probably finish it in the next one but
it was really interesting and I liked it
it's unique I like that people don't do
very much different things when it comes
to horror people just follow the same
patterns sort of kind of like her dark
corridors ambience mm okay dump this
one's maybe a little overboard with jobs
characters good but it's fun anyway hope
you bros and your watching
it's a sky khon with today and here is
the Prophet
No whoa what the [ __ ]
cop they don't like that no no you don't
exist
you don't exist you don't [ __ ] excess
tits on drill kiss under